to baby
danny lee's bro
[Laughter]
fight hit the bowling alley maybe the
funniest fight i've ever seen him
have you seen it yeah bro it's it's
unreal all right
oh boy that's not good
yeah dude they've added the cartoon
music on it yeah yeah
i mean yo props to danny lee's brother
man
why would you roll alone yo
yeah why why props to him because he
said he was going to do it and then he
did it
why would you roll alone yo you get
props for getting beat up no yeah you
get props for like staying your ground
and like going to do it you're like yo
if you're in my city or whatever like
that i'm going to come check you and he
wouldn't do it and he knew that all
these guys were there and they were
probably going to beat his ass and maybe
he thought he was going to land one shot
or do something like that but like he
rolled alone and did it and maybe he
rolled alone because
he thought if he had more dudes if
someone's gonna get killed
because if he rolls with four dudes they
also got four dudes guns might get taken
out and who knows who doesn't go home
that night this is technically his
brother-in-law so it's almost like i'm
showing up this is for my sister yeah he
gotta show up for he said online i'm
gonna go check you
he went to go check him
he gets to say yo they jumped me they
had five dudes he's too [ __ ] to
actually fight me now he never gets to
acknowledge this ever again
right the baby gets to go
i [ __ ] that dude up don't come at me
you're gonna get [ __ ] up he gets to
look like a big tough guy he gets a
bunch of social media clout everything's
good
nobody was really that hurt and now they
get to squash beef and eventually cause
he because i think that this guy gets to
look brave he took all five
[ __ ] by himself
him sliding into the bowling lane might
have saved his life because then the
five guys that are trying to stomp you
out
they can't get a good leverage point
yeah real talk of bowling alley is a
great place to get jumped yeah outside
like the bowling balls and [ __ ] that
they could throw at you like
the fact that nobody has enough traction
to really add some power yeah one
hundred percent especially if you know
where you got you can just run on the
middle lane like you gotta know that
going into it like i could just jump on
the side be good and then be good get
some real truck plank a little but they
don't know that and then they slide like
that boom game [ __ ] home alone like
you got to see that going i don't know
why yeah i mean i just wish his homies
didn't jump in because the baby [ __ ]
that guy up on his own that was one
punch from the baby right they sent him
[ __ ]
sliding on this it was a spare it was a
spirit yeah it was pretty good honestly
yeah i don't know i don't know al you
seem less uh less impressive i just i
just think it was a stupid move like
don't
say you're gonna do something publicly
and then like
he can actually get charged right now he
got beat up and if the baby wanted to
press charges he could pressure ah
goodbye the baby can't because he's
he's he's thugging bro no i know that's
true but i'm just saying it's just
stupid like don't promote your crimes
yeah yeah no that's also true don't
promote your crimes but i guess what i'm
saying is like if you are the person
that's saying you're about that life and
you know the dudes in town
where were you bro true
because you know for a fact he's going
to come out and say
if it you know what what yeah but he's
not famous he's the baby's
[ __ ] he's danny lee's brother so like
he could easily not show up and one or
two people for a day might be like yo
where the [ __ ] is he at but nobody cares
you're not famous you have no [ __ ]
reputation to uphold you have no image
to uphold does he want to be famous yes
i'm saying if you don't want to be
famous who cares about your image i talk
[ __ ] i gotta go back it up nobody cares
yeah i mean he wants to be famous yeah
so then this is great you get some fame
out of it okay fair enough if he wants
to be famous then it makes sense what is
he trying to do i'm not too sure but i
know he's one of those types he talks
about himself in third person
oh god then i'm glad he got his ass beat
yeah
hopefully they beat that out of him
what else we got mark all right you want
to talk about kodak getting shot at
bieber's party jesus christ how do you
get shot i don't understand you know the
crazy thing is if we were in town during
the super bowl which we were planning to
be because we were gonna do shows around
this weekend and actually spend the
super bowl in l.a we moved some stuff
we would be at that party 100 percent
like we would be at that party i mean
like
that's that's family you know scooter is
right bieber's manager yeah right so
he's going to definitely say you'll come
by the bieber event and we could have
diffused the situation we would have
saved kodak black we might have been on
the refusal or we would be dead
you guys wouldn't have been at the party
yeah bro why not
not that we would couldn't get in but
you wouldn't have gone because it was
the after party and you guys call it a
night uh
and i don't think that's fair to me
because i had a call it a night at the
regular party yeah probably yeah
probably would have tapped out yeah i
would have probably stayed out however
if i'm drinking if i'm drinking i'm
going for it i probably would have
stayed out yeah there's a very good
chance that we're at that party
i think there's a hundred percent chance
you have that party and if it's a if
it's a [ __ ] event like that i might
even stay up
i knew i was lying as soon as i said it
there's no way i'm going and i would
have protected kodak i actually feel bad
i wasn't there yeah i let him down now
is this the best thing that could happen
in kodak why make him chill for a minute
no any time a rapper gets shot and
doesn't die it's just an amazing boost
the only thing that would have been
better for his career would have been
dying exactly but this way he gets to
not die yes exactly no because you know
dying is great for your numbers yeah but
now you get all this pr you get all this
news people like who's kodak black
they're looking on spotify they're
watching they're watching the music
videos they're listening to the songs
etc but now you get to talk about
getting shot and then you're on
what is it uh twitter live or whatever
that [ __ ] is the next day yeah did you
see that he was in like a spaces room
twitter spaces i think they have this
kind of like live their clubhouse
clubhouse version yeah and uh but yeah
this is great for him
especially if you're doing like the
super thug thing like this is for not
getting shot matter of fact if you're
super thug and you haven't survived
getting a shot
are you really super thugging um
i i heard from somebody out there that
this might have been retaliation for
the comments he made after nipsey
passed oh [ __ ] yeah because they said
they were coming forward yo being a thug
that's awesome how do you hold on to
this [ __ ] remember
they're like [ __ ] wives dog how do
you remember all this negative [ __ ] we'd
be saying all the time just lock it away
oh my god bruh forget something nah they
don't forget dog yeah they're like
elephants there's this guy who's
hilarious do you guys know uh oh [ __ ]
what is his name [ __ ] mack
55th street oh yeah yeah that guy he's
always on no jumper podcast he's like
this guy's probably like the most uh
famous [ __ ] now like online and he's
like really charismatic dude he's like
really funny he's got a big five tattoo
on the side of his face and like
everything is i'm gonna keep it 55th
street like it's just hilarious and um
some facebook posts surfaced when he was
a kid so claiming a different set we're
talking about like super young right
claiming maybe talking [ __ ] about the
set that he's currently in
and he had to go back to the
neighborhood and get
i guess what's called dp'd disciplined
and he went back in there and just
started tussling with some dudes he got
some shots and he got some shots off
they got some shots off and and that's
what it was but it's like he's putting
on the set he's the most recognizable
and probably famous crypt that's not
snoop right now and even he had to go
back to the neighborhood and the og's
had to go yo you for when he was a kid
like they're cancelling gang members for
old tweets
in that crazy life
gang members can't even get away with
tweeting his [ __ ] up [ __ ] when they're
you know 10 years ago yeah
so he had to go fight to like that's
your punishment yeah and then see how
you hold up nice more you just get
jumped but you can fight back okay yeah
gang members they forgive
should we do that with people who tweet
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah
gets to be the one doing the dpn uh
that's actually decent so you have some
homophobic tweets from back in the day
yeah the gays jump you bro
[Music]
real talk that's actually a good idea
so then you only talk [ __ ] against
people that can't fight there it is
vegans
from all that [ __ ] you want vegans let's
go
let's make it happen but for real that's
interesting pacifist
pacific that's a good group yeah they
can't actually do anything religious
groups well certain ones yeah certain
ones yeah
was about that action yeah 100.
[Applause]